Don't look now, but writer-director Leigh
Whannell's The Invisible Man is shaping up
to be one of the year's biggest horror hits.
The flick has been screened for critics, and
while there is still an embargo on formal
reviews, they're taking to social media in
droves to report that The Invisible Man is
something you need to see.
It's apparently a tense, terrifying thriller
grounded in real-world issues and featuring
a performance for the ages from Elisabeth
Moss.
A bit of background: The Invisible Man is
the result of a major course-correction by
studio Universal, which at one point was planning
a Marvel-esque series of interconnected franchises
based on its classic monster properties.
The first in the series, 2017's remake of
The Mummy, also ended up becoming the last
when it was savaged by critics and underperformed
severely at the box office.
Plans for big-budget tentpole features starring
A-list actors based on properties like Bride
of Frankenstein and The Invisible Man were
subsequently scrapped, and Universal wisely
decided to scale back its plans.
"Okay, we're just going to take a minute and
come up with a new plan."
"You don't know what you're doing."
"I know exactly what I'm doing."
Universal's new approach is to make modestly-budgeted,
updated takes on its properties crafted by
experienced horror filmmakers.
To help implement this plan, the studio partnered
with the hitmaking horror studio Blumhouse,
and the new Invisible Man is the first fruit
of that partnership.
The flick may only be Whannell's third feature
as a director, but the writer and co-creator
of Saw proved long ago that he knows a thing
or two about horror.
His previous movie in the director's seat,
2018's Upgrade, also showed a ton of promise
- promise upon which he has apparently now
delivered.
Critics are going absolutely bonkers over
The Invisible Man, in no small part due to
his direction, and to Elisabeth Moss' committed
performance.
Moss stars as Cecilia Kass, whose boyfriend
Adrian was an abusive jerk to her before he
apparently went off and mysteriously died.
Cecilia eventually becomes convinced that
her deceased former lover has returned to
torment her as an invisible man, although
she understandably has a hard time getting
anyone to believe her.
Critic Witney Seibold was one of many to praise
the film's examination of the dynamics of
abuse while also standing in awe of just how
scary it is.
He tweeted:
"Leigh Whannell's #TheInvisibleMan is not
just one of the most tightly-wound thrillers
in recent memory, but it is a pertinent and
all-too-real look at the panic and damage
left by an abusive relationship.
Elisabeth Moss digs deep."
We Live Entertainment editor-in-chief Scott
Menzel concurred, tweeting:
"The Invisible Man is [a] tension filled thrill-ride
from start to finish [...] Elisabeth Moss
delivers a haunting & captivating performance
that is amongst some of her finest work to
date."
The Playlist's Griffin Schiller called the
film:
"...a spine-tingling modern horror classic
in the making.
Poignant & timely, packed full of edge of
your seat anxiety inducing suspense!
Sound & production design are MASSIVE standouts
but Elizabeth Moss OWNS this film."
Virtually all of the critics who took to Twitter
to freak out over The Invisible Man were in
awe of Whannell's command of his craft, and
his ability to generate nerve-wracking suspense.
Daily Dead News managing editor Heather Wixson
tweeted:
"Leigh Whannell has crafted a masterclass
in tension and terror, and I think my jaw
was left on the floor at least twice.
Completely thrilling, visceral and emotional."
Meanwhile, Fringefeed editor Julian Wright
offered the kind of praise we can really get
behind.
He said:
"I needed to pee the entire film but couldn't
move.
Then got home and was convinced an invisible
entity was standing in the corner watching
me.
It's that great."
Just in case you're not yet convinced, consider
the words of Coming Soon contributor Grant
Hermanns, whose praise might seem hyperbolic
if we hadn't gotten the chills just from watching
the flick's trailers.
Hermanns tweeted:
"[The Invisible Man] is one of the best horror
films in years.
Leigh Whannell has set the bar high for the
rest of the year.
It's tense from start to finish in the same
vein as a Hitchcock masterpiece.
I seriously can't recommend this movie enough,
I plan to see it multiple times!"
With initial reactions like this, The Invisible
Man could wind up being a major hit - out
of nowhere.
You'll get the chance to see the film for
yourself when it opens on February 28.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.